mais d'abord le récit de cette première
journée d'examen du texte immigration
ici au Sénat résumé par Jonathan
duprieèz c'est le coup d'envoie d'une
apre bataille politique le Sénat examine
à partir d'aujourd'hui le texte
immigration main de fois reporté par le
gouvernement selon l'exécutif ce projet
de loi se veut un texte d'équilibre
aussillant entre un volet répressif et
un autre plus social géralde d'armanin
en a présenté les contours face au
sénateurs le texte que propose le
gouvernement
ici devant vous est ouvert à la
discussion avec le Parlement avec le
Sénat pour qu' construire ensemble un
texte ferme un texte juste et surtout un
texte efficace seulement le chemin est
miné pour le gouvernement qui ne pourra
se passer des voies de la droite pour
faire adopter son texte ELR a déjà posé
ses lignes rouges la droite réclame la
suppression pure et simple de l'article
3 du texte il concerne la création d'un
titre de séjour pour pour les métiers en
tenstion la droite y dénonce un appel
d'air migratoire on ne peut pas toujours
dire que l'immigration soit une chance
pour la France évidemment on peut penser
et on peut voir que les étrangers
peuvent peuvent sans doute utiliser leur
force à occuper un certain nombre de
métiers en France mais c'est plus me
semble-t-il une question d'organisation
du travail qui est propre à notre marché
du travail qu'autre chose mais la droite
sénatoriale risque de se trouver en
difficulté pour bâtir sa du texte car
les centristes alliés de LR au sein de
la majorité sénatoriale sont eux
favorables au maintien de l'article 3 un
point de blocage à ce stade à l'instant
présent il n'y a pas de compromis mais
je crois le compromis toujours toujours
possible alors ce n'est pas simplement
par tempérament optimistme mais parce
que c'est d'abord une exigence nous
avons une obligation de résultat quant à
la gauche elle essaie elle aussi d'avoir
voix au chapitre côte à côte au Sénat ce
matin députés et sénateurs ont martelé
qu'il défendrait le versant social du
texte vote de l'article 3 mais aussi de
l'article 4 qui vise à exempter certains
demandeurs d'asile d'une période de
carence avant de travailler la gauche se
prononcera aussi en faveur du maintien
de l'aide médicale d'État dans un
contexte où la droite est très à
l'offensive et cherche à sortir le texte
le plus rétrograde possible il est
important qu'en face les gens qui ont
quelques convictions qui considèrent que
l'écrasante majorité des étrangers qui
sont sur notre sol veulent simplement
travailler et vivre dignement il faut
que cette voix là elle se fasse entendre
le texte immigration sera examiné au
Sénat jusqu'au 14 novembre date du vote
solennel final le texte immigration et
son ministre soutention c'est le thème
de notre débat avec Béatrice giblelin
bonsoir bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes
géographe et directrice de la revue
Hérodote Frédéric dab bonsoir et bien
bienvenue directeur général de l'Ifop
Benjamin monrel bonsoir bienvenue à vous
aussi constitutionnaliste maître de
conférence endroit publi à Paris de
Panthéon Assas et vous publiez la France
en miette aux éditions du SER Mathieu
croissand éditorialiste politique
bonsoir Mathie de vous retrouver sur sur
ce plateau je commence par ce courrier
envoyé par Emmanuel Macron au chef de
parti il les il les invite pour ne pas
dire il les convoque à une nouvelle
réunion de de Saint-Denis le 17 novembre
prochain Béatrice giblelin il renouvelle
sa proposition d'élargir le champ du
référendum aux questions de société et
notamment aux questions migratoires le
le le le CLIN d'œil il est il peut pas
être plus il est énorme énorme au par de
droite il est énorme c'est c'est
vraiment bon je veux dire ça mange pas
de pain hein ça arrive au bon moment euh
bien sûr la ficelle est est vraiment
comme vous voulez le dire énorme euh ils
peuvent difficilement dire non euh ça
n'aurait absolument aucun sens qu'il
disent qu'il veent qu'il veulent pas
discuter de ce projet-là ceci étant euh
ce référendum puisqueil faut que ça soit
un changement de la Constitution parce
que c'est pas dans le champ possible des
référendum euh pose toute la question
effectivement trouver une majorité au
Parlement donc on peut considérer ça
comme une certaine hilité même si elle
est tellement visible que je me demande
c'est comme un gros nez rouge sur un
clown quoi euh est-ce que c'est vraiment
ça qui sera le plus le le le plus
efficace pour que la droite euh puisse
voter ce texte parce que c'est c'est
c'est ça essayz de les attirer dans dans
les dans les filets de du vote de ce
texte je je je je n'en suis pas sûr
parce que on a l'impression de ce qu'on
voit C début de débat que c'est pas au
fond
l'intérêt commun qui qui prend le dessus
mais c'est des stratégies des uns des
autres LR qui règle des comptes avec
Darmanin voilà je trouve qu' on sent un
peu tout ça quand même on va y revenir
et notamment à l'équilibre et au contenu
du du texte Benjamin Morel sur le le le
fait de d'élargir le champ du férendom
enfin on va peut-être se poser les mêmes
questions que pour savoir s'il y a une
majorité pour pour pour cette loi c'est
il va falloir trouver une beaucoup plus
large majorité pour pour faire cette
cette réforme constitutionnel c'est
quand même un des enjeux majur gag bien
sûr c'est pas gagné hein auà de la
promesse au-delà de la promesse vous
n'avez jamais eu de réforme globale de
la Constitution quand vous aviez un
sénat et une assembl munpale qui était
pas de la même majorité politique on a
modifié quelques articles mais de
réforme parce que vous parlez de
l'article 11 mais il y a également le
RIC qui aurait également la
décentralisation donc déjà ça paraît mal
parti ensuite on na jamais eu de réforme
de la contion quand vous aviez une
majorité relative à l'Assemblée
nationale sauf en 196
à l'époque de Goul dissous l'Assemblée
nationale qui a d'abord fait tomber
Pompidou et il utilise l'article 11 qui
aujourd'hui pour des raisons de
jurisprudence constitutionnelle n'est
plus possible donc vous voyez que c'est
quand même assez mal engagé l'affaire
quand à ce qu'il propose Emmanuel Macron
il dit d'accord référendum sur
l'immigration mais attention touche pas
au droit pénal intéressant parce que
quand même il y a un volet pénal dans
l'immigration il dit peut-être pas un
référendum sur la fin de vie mais ce qui
pose problème c'est la dépénalisation
justement de l'thonasie donc le volet
pénal voyez bien que là-dessus on est en
effet dans quelque chose un gros bonbon
qui est donné à à la droite on en donne
un petit peu à la pour la fin de vie à
la gauche on parle également
decentralisation ça fait plaisir au
Sénat mais tout en sachant très bien que
juridiquement ça va être très difficile
à construire et qui a très très loin de
la coupe auè pour que ce soit adopté
alors vous parlez finalement l'un et
l'autre de communication politique c'est
un peu ce qui ressort des des débats de
ces derniers jours ou semaines et et des
premières heures ici au Sénat mais ça
continue fréric Daab avec reconquête et
sa candidate aux élections européennne
Mario maréchal qui propose un référendum
d'initiative partagé sur l'immigration
et elle appelle ériic cotti Jordan
Bardella Nicolas duponénur là rejoindre
dans l'initiative là aussi on sait bien
que vu la forme actuelle du référendum
d'initiative partagé il y a à peu près
aucune chance que ça aboutissetionnel
donc oui en plus et et je pense que
c'est le type en fait d'initiative qui
je dirais déroute les Français on parle
d'élargissement du champ du référendum
depuis relativement en fait longtemps la
rencontre de Saint-Denis je rappelle que
c'est le sujet euh que les Français ont
le moins évoqué dans leur dans leur
conversation dans notre baromètre il
fudicial pour match et SUD RADIO où
chaque mois on teste le fait d'avoir
parlé de s'être exposé à toute une série
de sujets c'est loin des préoccupations
des Français en tout cas la mécanique
référendaire la mécanique
constitutionnelle est très loin ce qui
ne veut pas dire que l'immigration n'est
pas un sujet pour les Français c'est de
plus en plus un sujet qui est de moins
en moins quiiv entre la gauche et la
droite même si ça ne voit pas ça ne se
voit pas quand vous parlez des
différentes initiative qui est un sujet
qui est de moins en moins ça se voit pas
non plus dans les prises de parole au
Sénat qu'on a entendu à l'ANT il a
parfois euh en fait un décalage on on
parlera des métiers en tension la
régularisation des S papiers et
majoritaire chez sympathisantir alors
que c'est alors que les alors que le les
elur sont vent debout en tout cas c'est
un sujet qui est de moins en moins
étanche pour les français puisque ils
associent imigration et insécurité ce
lien ne se faisait quasiment pas par le
passé sauf du côté du discours du Front
national de Jean-Marie Le Pen ils
associent immigration et terrorisme
parfois immigration et questions
économiques mais c'est vrai que cette
question d'élargissement du champ du
référendum on ne voit pas la finalité on
ne voit pas le chemin donc ça ne dit
rien et je pense que c'est
contreproductif pour le gouvernement
parce que ça installe plus que jamais
une grille de lecture qui était
absolument absente lors du premier
quinena c'est l'idée d'inaction l'idée
d'immobilisme et là c'est vraiment
nouveau et ça repose ai la question de
la la la parole politique la parole
politique do
per qui do transform pour le coup c'est
pas forcément quelque chose qui
s'adresse aux Français ce nez rouge que
vous décriez en fait c'est c'est faire
de la politique et c'est vrai qu'il y en
a pour tout le monde parce qu'il y en a
pour la droite qui réclame à cor et à ce
référend et l'extrême droite ce
référendum sur sur l'immigration il y en
a pour la gauche aussi avec la révision
du fameux référendum d'initiative pour
partager en tout cas les pistes qui sont
dessinées puisque ça serait plus 10 % du
corps électoral à rassembler en
signature ce qui est absolument immense
et et très très difficile à atteindre
mais simplement 1 million de signatures
donc là on est sur quelque chose qui est
quand même plus acceptable par exemple
le projet vous savez il y av eu une
demande de référendum sur les la la
privatisation d'Aéroport de Paris Milon
voilà exactement ça l'aurait fait donc
la gauche va avoir du mal à à à ne pas y
aller ou à dire je veux pas discuter de
ça parce que on l'a bien vu pendant le
débat sur les retraites ils étaient là
référendom d'intiative partagé c'est
impossible donc il y en a pour tout le
monde voilà et c'est un coup politique
d'Emmanuel Macron qui est qui est chargé
de de de un peu de faire descendre la
pression sur sur ce texte retraite en
disant il y a un coup à jouer après si
vous jouez le jeu alors on va parler du
du du contenu du fond de ce de de ce
texte qui est présenté depuis cet
après-midi au au au Sénat pour je
propose de réécouter tiens l'argument
principal utilisé brandi par Gérald
armanin pour justifier l'examen rapide
de ce texte on est quelques jours après
l'assassinat terroriste du professeur
Dominique
Bernard le texte immigration tel que
nous l'avons proposé et adopté par la
commission des Lois du Sénat nous aurait
permis de pouvoir obtenir la levée des
protections du terroriste Daras qui à
l'époque n'était pas considéré comme
auteur terroriste Béatrice giblelin cet
argument est-ce qu'il vous semble
valable est-ce que cette loi va
permettre d'exclure plus facilement les
immigrés qui rejettent les lois de notre
ré ils essayent puisque ils vont
normalement dans la loi on lève le fait
d'être arrivé avant l'âge de 13 ans en
France et si on devient délinquant euh
après on on pourra être
euh exclu de bon et et et et renvoyé euh
mais ce qui est sûr c'est que c'est
entendu par l'opinion publique euh qui
effectivement cette argument qu'il prend
en disant mais si euh on n'avait pas
pris cette euh cette décisionl c'est
sous Sarkozi si je me trompe pas qu'on
avait pris ça euh et bien il pourrait
euh on aurait pu le renvoyer et voilà et
et ça c'est entendu et ça c'est entendu
euh dans dans le sondage qui était paru
dans le Parisien euh on a quand même
plus de 70 % des Français qui trouvent
que cette loi est bonne et bien je pense
pas qu'il connaissent très très bien
l'ensemble des articles de la loi mais
je pense que ça il ils ont dû le
mémoriser parce que ça a eu un tel
impact si cet assassinat que le fait
qu'on puisse dire cela aujourd'hui leur
semble il y a une demande de fermeté et
de renvoyer ce qui est considéré comme
des délinquants dangereux pour pour les
Françis je viens vers vous dans un temps
mais Frédéric dab effectivement est-ce
que on va a cette volonté d'équilibre du
texte qui était incarné par Gérald Haran
d'un côté Olivier du SO de l'autre on
voit quand même beaucoup moins du
travail faut-il le rappeler mais dans
dans cet équilibre que demandent
prioritairement les français plutôt de
l'ordre plutôt de la sévérité oui dans
le contexte actuel et vous avez raison
de rappeler le cas Dominique Bernard qui
a réactivé le traumatisme très fort
Samuel Patier c'est vrai que l'argument
fil d'Arian si on avait fait si on
aurait évité ça c'est évident que
c'estit un argument AB absolument massif
en terme d'adhésion d'opinion publique
l'opinion publique attend bien sûr un un
durcissement j'ai enquête j'ai en tête
une enquêtephob du mois de septembre où
on a 86 % des Français qui sont
favorables par exemple à l'expulsion de
délinquants étrangers à l'issu de leur
peine et c'est majoritaire dans toutes
les familles politique y compris à la
France insoumise mais la question
migratoire au-delà de ce audelà de ce
durcissement il y a quand même l'idée de
la question de la remise en ordre la
question de la perte d'autorité de
l'état de l'État qui n'est plus maître
de ses frontières mais pour autant les
Français sont relativement équilibrés
aussi j'ai envie de dire presque
rocardien si on fait référence à la
fameuse phrase la fin des années 80
quand on teste l'adhésion à une phrase
que l'on que l'on propose au français
depuis des années c'est le devoir de la
France d'accueillir des personnes
fillant la guerre ou la misère on trouve
peu ou pro une petite majorité de
Français donc l'équilibre jambe gauche
jambe droite jambe sociale jambe
répressive peut avoir un succès et
d'ailleurs elle avait eu cette cet
équilibre au moment de la loi colon un
relatif succès puisque les Français
avaient soutenu la loi dans la mesure où
elle paraissait elle avait été critiquée
pour son laxisme à droite et pour ce
côté répressif à gauche mais j'ai envie
de dire le contexte a quand même très
fortement changé l'imposition des
thématiques sécuritaires immigration et
surtout terrorisme on fait on fait
beaucoup bouger la ligne vers une vraie
demande de fermeté ouis mais avec une
question qui qui me semble quand même
majeure Morel c'est c'est comment ce
texte va-t-il va-t-il être appliqué
c'est le 30e texte immigration depuis le
début des années 80 est-ce que c'est pas
aussi la crédibilité du texte législatif
bah c'est la crédibilité en effet tout à
fait alors sur haras géralmana a raison
aujourd'hui vous avez besoin d'une
condamnation si vous êtes rentré à 20 13
ans sur le territoire pour être expulsé
avec le texte qui devait être adopté ce
ne serait plus forcément le cas il
faudrait une présomption et cetera donc
on pourrait éventuellement voir un
certain nombre d'évolutions dans ce
texte mais ensuite mais après c'est
comment il sera appliqué sera-t-il
appliquable vous allez prononcer plus au
qtf c'est merveilleux mais une fois que
vous avez exactement une fois que vous
les avez prononcé et ben il vous faut
les délaisser passer consulair alors la
droite a rajouté un certain nombre de
disposition permettant de faire pression
ou de donner à l'état la capacité il l'a
déjà mais de faire pression sur les
États qui sont les états et bien
d'origine des personnes soumis à uneqtf
le problème c'est que vous voyez combien
ça a bien marché avec l'Algérie ça nous
a fâché avec le Maroc cela dit mais ça
n'a pas vraiment fonctionné jusqu'à
présent parce que le rapport de force en
tant que tel n'est pas forcément en la
faveur de l'État français dans ce type
d'échange et par ailleurs il y a
d'autres intérêts économiques
géopolitiques qui font que et bien on
n'a pas réellement aujourd'hui la
capacité de faire appliquer l'immense
majorité des obligations qui étent du le
territoire qu'on prononce déjà et c'est
quoi c'est de la mauvaise volonté c'est
parce que les textes tels qu'ils sont
écrits aujourd'hui ne
sont bien écrit c'est quoi c'est pas un
problème de loi c'est un problème
d'application de la loi c'est un
problème géopolitique c'est un problème
diplomatique d'un côté c'est un problème
et ça c'est notamment un autre une autre
chose que vis l'air c'est un problème
également d'hérarchie des normes parce
que si vous prenez une loi c'est
merveilleux mais la réalité c'est que
cette loi si elle est jugée contraire à
la Convention européenne des droits de
l'homme le juge s'en lave les mains et
ne l'applique pas et donc vous voyez que
là-dessus on rentre dans des
problématiques d'application de la loi
ou dans des problématiques
conventionnelles et à ce stade là le
risque en effet et ça serait la même
chose serait peut-être même pire si la
loi est adoptée demain par référendum et
bien c'est le risque d'une nouvelle
promesse de solution sur un sujet qui au
bout du compte et bien ne mènera pas de
vraie révolution ouais plus de sévérit
pour les ennemis de la République c'est
ce que promet le gouvernement écoutez
Olivier verrant sur la possibilité de
retirer un titre de séjour pour adhésion
à l'idéologie djihadiste le but il est
de faire en sorte que quand une personne
étrangère dans notre pays ne respecte
pas les valeurs de notre République par
son comportement par ses paroles met en
danger la cohésion de la nation met en
danger les valeurs républicaines
n'adhère pas aux valeurs qui sont les
nôtres et y compris d'ailleurs les
valeurs d'accueil des personnes qui ont
on besoin lorsque cette personne ne
s'inscrit pas dans les pas de la
République que la République ne soit pas
contrainte de la conserver sur son
territoire alors j'entends les les
arguments de d'Olivier verrand Béatrice
giblelin effectivement enfin je pense
qu'on peut tous adhérer à ce que à ce
que vient de dire le porte-parole du du
gouvernement la question c'est comment
on définit ses comportements hosyle aux
valeurs républicaines et on on en
revient à la à l'applicabilité du texte
le diable va se nicher dans les détails
dans les dans les mots dans les dans les
termes employés oui euh il faut quand
même pas négliger le le contexte
géopolitique dans
lequel cette phrase est prononcée hein
il y a eu quand même un assassinat d'un
professeur avec une extrême émotion
légitime bon
donc vous avez raison de poser la
question est-ce que ce sera possible ou
pas mais regardez quand même depuis
l'assassinat de Dominique Bernard je
crois que c'est 200 personnes qui ont
été ou qui sont en voie d'expuls
h
pourtite R ou ou supposer radical par
exemple le père qui tabassait son gamin
parce qu'il faisait mal ses prières ou
son Beaufils je sais pas si c'était son
fils ou son Beaufils a été renvoyé au au
Maghreb on ne sait pas exactement dans
dans quel pays donc bien sûr que ce sera
sans doute très difficile c'est pas
parce que c'est difficile que il faut
rester inactif vous et et je je je
pensais par exemple la Suède aujourd'hui
où on a quand même un gouvernement dans
lequel l'extrême droite est présent la
Suède a vu sa population étrangère
depuis le début du 21e siècle à
aujourd'hui de 10 % passé à 20 %. c'est
quand même colossal c'est quand même
extrêmement important et et on peut pas
dire si vous voulez que l'immigration ça
pose aucun problème aux électeurs à la
population ça ça n'a aucun sens de dire
ce genre de chose peut-être pouvait-on
le dire dans les années 70 ou 80 mais on
ne peut à à mon avis pu le dire
aujourd'hui et ils ont pris des des
décisions extrêmement fermes pour
essayer d'endiguer véritablement cette
cette
montée xénophobe extrêmement forte idaim
au Danemark avec un régime
socio-démocrate donc et ça me pose moi
derrière une question importante que
Benjamin Morel a soulevé c'est cuit de
l'Europe parce que si derrière l'Europe
systématiquement détricote ce que les
nations ou les États souverains essayent
de de tricoter alors on va avoir des
élections quand même pas en très
longtemps le 7 juin 2024 on risque
d'avoir dans C contexte là un vote qui
soit un vote hostile si vous voulez à un
discours très pro-européen en même temps
on dit l'immigration ça ne peut se
régler qu'au niveau de l'Europe mais en
même temps si on confie tout à l'Europe
avec la fameuse le le les drois de
l'homme mise en avant constamment comme
le disait Benjamin ben les jug S on lave
les mains et puis il vogue la galère on
change rien donc la question est
véritablement politique et géopolitique
me semble extrêmement important mais
elle est aussi juridique si on reprend
le cas de l'assassin du professeur
Dominique Bernard sa famille aurait pu
être expulsée en 2014 mais Benjamin
Morel il y a eu des associations des
partis politiques qui ont utilisé les
recours du droit on est dans un état de
droit ça ça continuera ça il y aura
toujours la possibilité de faire jouer
des recours oui bien sûr et les recours
vous pouvez les faire jouer à la fois au
niveau national et c'est là qu'on
retrouve le sujet également au niveau
international notamment avec la cour
européenne des droit de l'homme parce
que moi je veux bien quelqu'un qui
adhère à l'idéologie djihadiste vous
l'avez bien dit qu'est-ce que c'est
l'idéologie djihadiste et est-ce que ça
relève de la liberté d'expression ou
est-ce que c'est condamnable si c'est
condamnable pour vous pour moi c'est
également condamnable pour quelqu'un qui
arrive sur le territoire sans papier
mais si c'est pas condamnable pour des
individus entre guillemets des des
nationaux pourquoi est-ce que ce serait
plus condamnable pour quelqu'un qui
arrive sur le territoire ces questions
ben on va se la poser au niveau du juge
national on va se la poser au niveau du
Conseil constitutionnel parce est que
appment y avoir une saisine sur ce texte
et on va se la poser également
évidemment au niveau de la Convention
européenne des droits de l'homme si
l'article est évidé de sa substance
Infiné et bien en effet ça va poser ce
sujetl vous parlez du Danemark le
Danemark est dans une stratégie d'opting
out vis-à-vis du droit européen
autrement dit en matière de politique
migratoire le Danemark et bien
n'applique pas les traités européens ils
ont ménagé une exception depuis les
années 90 donc on risque d'avoir en
effet une mise en tension lors des
élections européennes de la
participation de la France à certaines
politiques c'est gà ce que propose le
rassemblement national ELR la loi
immigration et ben était une façon pour
le gouvernement de répondre à ça on
verra bien c'est le cas allez on ouvre
un nouveau chapitre dans dans ce débat
avec vous Mathieu pour s'intéresser au
ministre lui-même Gérald daranin qui
joue quand même assez gros sur ce texte
oui ça fait un an qu'il y travaille un
an qu'il subit les ordres et les
contreordres d'une certaine façon un
jour il y avait une loi un jour de loi
un jour pas de loi puis de nouveau une
loi ça fait un an qu'il subit la
pression du rassemblement national de de
la nups un an que tout le monde l'attend
au tournant y compris dans sa propre
majorité où certains serait pas fâché de
le voir trébucher alors Premier ministre
qui se sentait pousser des ailes au
point de revendiquer Matignon en juillet
dernier et qui Lorne ouvertement sur
2027 depuis la rentrée c'est donc un
test grandeur nature parce que qu'il le
rate ou qu'il le passe de toute façon ça
sera pour sa pomme comment il s'y prend
ben c'est là qu'on va voir s'il existe
ou non une méthode d'armanin il l'a dit
hier sur France 2 j'ai tout montant et
je suis opposé au 493 c'est amusant
parce que c'est exactement l'inverse de
la méthode borne qu'on a vu pour les
retraites qui elle disait ben non il y a
pas le temps il faut que ce soit un
débat trè encadré en 15 jours et qui a
fini par passer par un 493 alors on
verra si il mène sa barque différemment
ce qui est sûr c'est qu'il s'est
beaucoup activé il multiplie les coups
de fil les réunions les déjeunés ça
depuis maintenant 6 mois pour tenter de
convaincre les parlementaires à droite
il envoyaé de nouveaux signaux
supplémentaires de durcissement
notamment on en parlait depuis
l'assassinat de Dominique Bernard sur
l'aide médicale d'État par exemple sur
les expulsions à gauche il se pose en
garant du fameux articles 3 qui prévoit
donc la régularisation des sanspapiers
qui travaillent dans les métiers dit en
tension l'idée c'est d'aller chercher
les parlementaires un par un de
fracturer notamment la droite
sénatoriale ici et puis l'assemblée
d'essayer de de les ramener un par un
c'est un peu à l'image pour le coup de
ce qu'avait fait Emmanuel Macron quand
il était ministre de l'Économie et qu'il
avait voulu faire passer sa loi il y
était pas evenu mais il s'était pris si
j'ose dire 1493 de la part de Manuel
Vals qui voulait bien calmer ses
ambitions oui est-ce qu'il a des chance
Géral d'manin de réussir ben sur le
papier non a priori on rappelle qu'il a
qu'une majorité relative maintenant
c'est là qu'on va voir si c'est faire de
la politique d'une certaine façon il a
plus de chance s'il parvient à conserver
le fragile équilibre du texte on verra
comment il ressort du Sénat et comment
il sera à l'Assemblée il y arrivera s'il
parvient à mettre la droite face ses
contradictions et d'une certaine façon à
prendre l'opinion à un témoin où on se
on en parlait à l'instant euh cette
cette opinion publique qui sans soutenir
Gérald armanin en tant que tel est quand
même assez raccord et soutient
l'ensemble du texte en tout cas si on en
croit le sondage paru dans le Parisien
hier sur l'ensemble des mesures
d'ailleurs et puis euh il y arrivera si
il réussit aussi à tenir les composantes
de la majorité c'estàd à faire en sorte
qu'elle ne fasse pas entendre leur voix
que pendant les retraites déjà elles se
sont muselé ça fait quand même un an
qu'elles ne disent pas grand-chose et là
on voit bien que l'aile gauche ou l'a
droite de la majorité et bien envie a
bien envie de de de se faire entendre ça
c'est loin d'être évident et puis enfin
il réussira si si bah s'il ne c pas ses
mauvaises habitudes évidment c'est les
coups de communication et les
provocations oui effectivement ça peut
faire partie du personnage fr dab est-ce
qu'il y a une surestimation médiatique
de Gérald daran si on
compare le nombre de fois le nombre de
fois où il est invité où on reprend ses
paroles et et son niveau de popularité
bah c'est pas moi de parler de
surestimation sousestimation en tout cas
il a une popularité c'est réel il fait
partie des ministres les plus populaires
avec Gabriel hatal et Bruno Le Maire
c'est quelqu'un et j'entends bien ce que
vous avez dit sur l'incapacité du
politique a changé les choses sur la
question migratoire des contraintes qui
essayent tant bien que mal de montrer
qu'il peut faire bouger les choses moi
en terme de communication il y a quelque
chose qu'il fait depuis une quinzaine de
jours que je trouve extrêmement inédit
et très spectaculaire tous les soirs en
fin de journée sur son compte Twitter
son compte X il publie il dit voilà nous
avons nous avons j'ai ou nous avons
aujourd'hui expulsé x personnes avec une
sorte de description on donne bien sûr
pas les noms mais les initiales lâche on
donne pas le paysit d'origine mais voilà
pourquoi la personne a été expée il
essaye de manière un peu performative de
manière avec une logique testimoniale
qui en communication plaît beaucoup au
français c'est la preuve que on fait des
choses et c'est vrai que vous avez bien
raison Mathieu de citer l'Emmanuel
Macron de la loi de 2015 qui est
vraiment n'a pas en fait ménagé son
temps qui s'était même si je puis dire
çaavait suscité des louanges à droite
dans tous les rangs de l'Assemblée
nationale pour finalement tomber de haut
avec le 493 il y a du ML Macron 2015 il
y a aussi du Nicolas Sarkozi 2002 2007
il resté quasiment 5 ans place Bovo à
part l'intermè à c'est-à-dire essayer de
de faire venir sur lui l'agenda fait
médiatique le susciter le provoquer
prendre tous les ballons quittent
parfois à déraper la faire Benzema si je
peux dire il y a quelques temps le Stade
de France mais pour répondre à votre
question du début je n'ai pas vu dans sa
popularité des moments de creux de
baisse très forte il garde un socle très
élevé et puis et puis il arrive à cocher
des cases de soutien dans deux familles
politiques Renaissance la majorité
présidentielle et également LR pour la
parler d'une actualité récente dans
notre enquête ifob pour le CRIF sur la
question de l'antisémitisme et de la
lutte contre l'antisémitisme il
apparaissait quasiment en tête et parmi
les personnalités qui avaient le crédit
le plus fort donc surestimation
médiatique je ne dirais pas cela ben
Giblin euh Géral armanin c'est un ancien
euh du parti LR est-ce que c'est
forcément un atout pour lui aujourd'hui
puisqu'il prend son téléphone il va voir
les les sénateurs ou les députés les uns
après les autres B ça peut être ça peut
être les deux ça peut être un atout ou
ça peut être effectivement un handicap
c'est un atout parce qu'il les connaît
bien donc il peut les appeler il peut
discuter avec eux bon il a il a un
certain savoir-faire c'est évident mais
il peut passer pour le traître aussi
voilà et les traîtres on n'aime pas et
en plus il peut leur tailler des
croupières sérieusement si jamais il
était candidat ça les met eux met dans
un coin dont ils auront du mal à sortir
si sauf à se mettre de plus en plus sur
dans les pas du RN mais à ça à mon avis
c'est du Kiper gagne parce que plus ils
vont sur le terrain du RN plus c'est
Marine Le Pen qui tirera les les les
fruits de ça donc il est il est il est
raiment très habile moi je je je je
trouve il est un peu pressé il est un
peu pressé c'està dire l'exemple
d'Emmanuel Macron qui a réussi à se
faire élire très jeune président de la
République donne beaucoup d'idées à un
certain nombre de gens très jeunes
et je il se il se pense déjà avec ce
destin présidentiel dès 2027 je ne suis
pas sûr que ce que Macron a réussi
puisse se reproduire sur quelqu'un comme
Darmanin la la la prochaine fois
c'est c'est une chose d'être avec cette
ce capital de popularité c'est mais
c'est une autre chose quand on rentre
dans l'arè pour des présidentielles et
là je suis pas sûr que ça tienne la
route dans la tout à fait dans la durée
par rapport à d'autres types de
candidats alors parmi ceux qui n'ont pas
digéré la traittrise je reprends ce
terme là de de Géral il y a Olivier
marlex le président des députés LR qui
monte au créneau là depuis quelques
jours il proche de collecter le ministre
de l'intérieur des données sur les élus
de droite qui demandent des
régularisations de travailleurs sans
papier au préfet on écoute Olivier Marle
absolument scandaleux Jea quand les
parlementaires interviennent auprès d'un
préfet c'est auprès du préfet c'est le
préfet qui est au terme de la loi
aujourd'hui a le pouvoir de de de
régulariser au cas par cas le ministre
de l'Intérieur n'a absolument rien à
faire dans cette procédure et donc c'est
une demande de fichage de fichage
d'opposants politiques et c'est
absolument scandaleux j'ai saisi laacnil
j'attends avec intérêt sa réponse
Benjamin Morel c'est une bonne guerre on
s'est tous dit ça en entendant en
entendant la phrase de la première
phrase de viarlex mais est-ce que c'est
légal est-ce que le ministre a le droit
d'aller collecter eu alement s'il
établit un fichier et cetera non c'est
un problème ensuite qu'il puisse y avoir
des remonté des préfectures ça ça peut
s'envisager mais la réalité c'est que là
on est dans une bataille très très
politique et que l'argument d'Olivier
marlex c'est très très politique comme
ce projet est très très politique il les
place quand même devant leur
contradiction là les les les les élus
députés de droite mais évidemment
l'objectif du gouvernement c'est à la
fois d'adresser un message à l'électorat
juste avant les européennes en disant
regardz on fait quelque chose pour
l'immigration et le RN n'a pas le
monopole du sujet etess de neutraliser
LR qui aujourd'hui a un problème c'est
un parti qui est prê en éto entre le RN
et la majorité le but de la majorité
c'est de de de LR c'est de desserrer cet
étau c'est pour ça que
fondamamentalement
aura toutes les peines du monde à voter
ce projet pas tant pour son contenu et
pour une question de positionnement
politique et là-dessus et bien regardez
aujourd'hui là où le Besse le Besse au
moins au Sénat sur le fameux article 3
c'est du domaine réglementaire h alors
je vous interroms parce qu'on on va on
va en parler en détail de ce de cet
article 3 dans dans une minute grâce à
Steve Jourdain je vous propose d'abord
d'écouter la première ministre sur ce
thème régularisation des travailleurs
sans papier dans les métiers en tension
elle justifie l'article 3 ellzabeth
borne il s'agit de permettre à des
personnes qui sont sur notre territoire
depuis des années qui sont bien intégrés
qui travaillent depuis des années de
pouvoir être régularisé et je pense que
beaucoup y compris d'employeurs
soulligne l'utilité de ce type d'article
évidemment l'intention du gouvernement
ça n'est pas contrairement à ce que je
peux entendre de faire des appels d'air
on est dans un pays où on a encore un
taux de chômage de plus de 7 % donc la
priorité c'est naturellement que les
emplois puissent être pourvus par ceux
qui n pas comme promistive Jourdin nous
a rejoint bonsoir St que prévoit cet
article 3 prévoit de délivrer vous savez
par cœur on a beaucoup parlé de cet
article it de délivrer de plein droit
c'est-à-dire de façon quasi automatique
une carte de séjour temporaire à un
étranger qui travaille pendant au moins
8 mois dans un secteur en tension ça
concerne par exemple la filière de la
restauration ou encore celle du bâtiment
concrètement on parle d'environ 7000
régularisation par an si cet article
venait à être adopté dans les mêmes
termes dans les deux chambres du
Parlement alors on n'y est pas encore
d'autant que ici au Sénat la la majorité
est très divisée on est d'accord ni sur
le fond ni sur la forme de alors la
majorité sénatoriale c'est 133 sénateurs
LR plus les 56 élus du groupe Union
centriste les républicains ont déposé un
amendement de suppression de cet article
3 ça veut dire qu'ils veulent en fait le
retirer du texte on va voir cet
amendement de Bruno rotaillo il regrette
que l'article 3 du projet de loi en
prévoyant au niveau législatif la remise
euh de plein droit d'un titre de séjour
à à l'étranger travaillant dans les
métiers en ttion procède un renversement
préoccupant de la logique présidente
régular
des S papiers fin de citation autrement
dit hors de question de voter ce que
propose le gouvernement à noté que côté
LR tous ne sont pas du même avis
certains estiment que la position de
Bruno retaillot est trop catégorique
aussi le cas des centristes oui il
propose un compromis entre l'exécutif et
leslr un genre d'article 3 à minima qui
ne reviendrait pas à donner
automatiquement un titre de séjour aux
étrangers mais qui nécessiterait et bien
le contrôle des préfets le sénateur est
rapport rorteur Philippe boncarer résume
cette position de compromis des
centristes écoutezle hypothèse une on
travaille à partir de l'article 3 actuel
on dit que c'est un titre accordé par
les préfets dans le cadre de leur
pouvoir discrétionnaire et on supprime
le caractère obligatoire de
l'autorisation de l'employeur deuxième
hypothèse on reste dans le cadre de la
circulaire Vals la situation actuelle
dont j'observe que personne ne demande
l'abrogation et on se limite simplement
modifier le code du
travail avec la circulaire Val si je
suis un étranger qui travaille j'ai
besoin de l'autorisation de mon
employeur pour être régularisé avec le
compromis proposé par les centristes
cette autorisation ne sera plus
nécessaire la gauche pourrait-elle voter
cette proposition des centr ce qui est
sûr c'est que la gauche sénatoriale
est-elle aussi favorable à la
régularisation des étrangers dans les
métiers en tension au Sénat la gauche
représente 99 sénateur communiste
socialiste écologiste si on fait un peu
d'arithmétique Thomas on se rencontre
qu'à l'heure où l'on parle avec le
soutien des sénateurs macronistes la
suppression de l'article 3 ne récolte
pas une majorité de voix très
schématiquement 195 sénateurs sur 348
sont pour la régularisation des sans
papiers l'article 3 ne devrait donc pas
être supprimé il pourrait être réécrit
avant d'être adopté toute la question
est de savoir dans quel état il sortira
du Sénat merci beaucoup Steve pour tout
toutes ces tous ces détails puis on a
fait des matths grâce à vous ça fait
toujours du bien de refaire un peu de
je je moi j'ai l'impression je sais pas
vous hein mais de revivre un débat qu'on
a certainement eu dans la même
configuration au moment de la réforme
des retraite vous voyez ce que je veux
dire c'estàd que on fait nos comptes et
puis ça termine comment par un 49 que
c'est pas le même enjeu c'est vrai que
ça rappelle furieusement le débat sur la
réforme des retraite ses contages mais
par rapport à ce qu'a dit Benjamin Morel
il y a une composante que je rajouterai
c'est le peuple le peuple de droite les
sympathisans de droite qui veulent qui
attendent peut-être que ça bouge en
matière d'immigration qui sont
favorables à une petite majorité c'est
une enquêtifope du mois de septembre à
la régularisation de sans papier
exerçant dans les métiers en tenstion
parce que la la notion de métier en
tenstion fait sens maintenant dans
l'opinion publique parce qu'il y a cette
idée que il y a toute une série
d'emplois non pourvu alors sur la
réforme des retraites on avait un peuple
de droite extrêmement fracturé qui était
dans une adhésion très faible et des
parlementaires des champs et des villes
c'est-à-dire à l'Assemblée plutôt très
défavorable à la réforme en étant
schématique au Sénat prêt à la voter
donc c'est sur un enjeu assez différent
c'est pas le même contexte politique et
la même pression si je puis dire des
sympathisants de droite Mathieu je veux
juste un point commun mais qui est
annexe mais c'est qu'il y a un très
grand absent comme il y a eu un très
grand absent dans la réforme des
retraites c'est le patronat français il
s'est il était muet et il n'est pas
intervenu pendant la réforme des
retraites et là il est muet et il n'est
pas intervenu le meddeef entreellement
CNPF qui était un partenaire social
train de Dir juste un lobby de baisse
des
impôs des entrepreneurs français ils
n'ont plus voix au chapitre ils ne se
donnent plus voix au chapitre sur ces
grands sujets de société qui les
concerne pourtant ils ne veulent pas
prendre la voix au chapitre c'est pas
qu'on ne leur donne pas ils ne veulent
absolument pas la prendre par exemple
sur les métiers entention on ne les
entend pas alors que officiellement
alors qu'officieusement ils le disent
tous on en a besoin mais ils disent tous
on en a besoin mais tant qu'à faire
pouvoir toujours disposer d'une main
d'œuvre
captive faisant pression sur les
salaires non seulement sur leur propre
salaire mais d'une certaine façon sur le
salaire des autres qu'on pourrait
employer au au au même métier ça les
arrange quand même aussi et moi je ne
comprends absolument pas pourquoi ni le
le gouvernement le fait très peu de dire
de les mettre devant leur contradiction
ou pas leur contradiction de sortir ce
qui est cette situation scandaleuse dans
la dans laquelle ils sont alors ce qui
ce qui est étonnant effectivement je
suis d'accord avec avec vous on nentend
pas le on nentend pas le MDF sur cette
question et finalement l'une des voix
qu'on entend c'est celle d'un ancien
candidat à la présidentielle le
socialiste Benoît amont qui est
maintenant directeur général de d'une
ONG qui s'appelle Singa global cette ONG
elle veut aider les entreprises
justement à trouver des immigrés leur
proposer les travails changer aussi le
regard de de notre société sur les
immigrés écoutez benoî il est très
précis on ne regarde pas ce qui'est la
contribution des immigrés aujourd'hui au
fait que sans leur cotisation il y a pas
d'équilibre de la sécurité sociale sans
leurs emplois il y a aujourd'hui de P
entiers de notre économie qui
s'effondrerait ça des responsables
politiques devraient le dire ils ne le
disent pas et c'est pour ça que cette
loi est une nouvelle loi qui ne servira
à rien sinon à rendre plus difficile la
vie de beaucoup de gens fr je voudrais
je vous redonne la parole sur le les
électeurs de du parti LR qu'est-ce
qu'ils disent exactement de cet article
3 et et de cette hypocrisie finalement
un peu un peu générale alors ils sont
une petite majorité de mémoire c'était
56 % à être favorable à une à une
régularisation de 100 papiers exerçant
dans des métiers en tension donc c'est
assez précis c'est pas une
régularisation massive il y a pas le
souvenir qui était très souvent réactivé
par les leaders de droite sur celle de
97 ou au moment de de la
cohabitationchirx était pas opposé du
tout unel Jospin et Jean-Pierre
chevement je crois avaient régularisé un
nombre important de sans papier et c'est
vrai que on a un peuple de droite qui
attend surtout de l'action sur cette
question migratoire qui attend une
remise en ordre qui attend que l'État
redevienne maître chez lui l'affaire de
l'Aquarius de la fin de l'année dernière
où 200 migrants c'était entre guillemets
évaporé de Marseille a beaucoup marqué
notamment à droite et donc on est
peut-être prêt du fait de cette question
de l'emploi qui n'est plus il faut bien
il faut aussi rappeler ça l'emploi le
chômage ne constitue plus une
préoccupation tion majeure des français
c'était la première préoccupation encore
en 2017 c'est la 12e dans les enquêtes
de l'ifope le le sujet c'est plus ne pas
avoir un travail c'est avoir un travail
qui paye mal en terme d'injustice en
terme de tension en terme de
préoccupation donc je pense qu'une
partie du peuple de droite est prêt à ce
que ce cet article soit voté si le reste
notamment la partie répressive parce que
sur la question migratoire aussi il faut
le rappeler et l'argument de Benoît
Hamont que l'immigration rapporte et
Cera à Tor a raison mais c'est
absolument inaudible par 3/4 des
français on a en fait un item qui
reprend le fameux livre de Bern stasie
l'immigration une chance pour la France
l'immigration rapporte plus qu'elle
qu'elle ne coûte c'est quasiment un/art
seulement des Français qui adhèrent et
une une infime minorité des
sympathisants de droite on se projette
sur ce qui se pourrait pourrait se
passer à l'Assemblée après l'examen ici
au Sénat et je reviens à mon parallèle
avec le avec les retraites Benjamin
Morel est-ce que il y a quand même une
probabilité de bis reppétita et donc de
49 93 alors ouais peut-être que même le
le parallèle serait plus à faire avec
les lois Macron al comer c'est-à-dire
que là s'il y a un 49 Aline à 3 soit il
est fait contre LR parce que et bien il
faut maintenir la cohésion de la
majorité avec l'article 3 l'équilibre
initial du texte soit il est fait contre
une partie de la majorité comme ça a été
le cas sous François Hollande avec
dedans notamment le président de la
commission des lois ce qui serait quand
même Baro et embêtant et ensuite une
trentaine de députés voire une partie du
MoDem qui V qui ne sont pas
fondamentalement favorables à un texte
plutôt aux conditions de LR et vous
voyez que le probl me c'est que si
jamais vous utilisez un 49 al 3 contre
votre propre majorité et bien il risque
de laisser quelques aigreurs à l'estomac
souvenez-vous ensuite des frondeurs et
cetera on a déjà une majorité relative
très divisée c'est en plus sur un texte
aussi important d'un point de vue
symbolique encore une fois pas tant sur
ce qu'il dit et sur le symbole qu'il
charit ce fameuse article 3 qui est du
domaine de la circulaire pour beaucoup
il est important d'un point de vue
symbolique et pour la gauche de la
majorité et pour ce serait perçu par la
gauche de la majorité comme comme une
défaite de de dire bon bah oui
effectivement peut utiliser une
circulaire pour préfet département par
département pour prendre ses
décisions scén à terme il y a deux
scénarios un peu cauchemardesques pour
pour le gouvernement ce serait en effet
d'utiliser un 49 àine 3 contre une
partie de sa majorité c'est veut dire
que cette majorité serait dé facto en
rupture de banc ou bien que le texte
passe aux conditions de LR mais Marine
Le Pen l'a évoqué avec les voix du RN et
si vous avez un texte qui passe LR RN
une partie de la majorité contre la
gauche de la majorité le signal est très
très mauvais Mathieu oui c'est c'est le
cadeau empoisonné de de Marine Le Pen
qui a dit ben moi je suis prête à voter
ce texte qui est un petit texte qui ne
rime à rien mais c'est quand même des
petites avancées alors il y aura la
question de de l'article 3 mais c'est
vrai que c'est un cadeau empoisonné pour
géralde harmanin parce que ça le marque
considérablement c'est une façon de lui
voler entre guillemets la vedette si
jamais son texte passé h merci beaucoup
merci à tous d'avoir participé à ce
débat je rappelle Benjamin Morel le
titre de votre livre la France en miette
qui est publié aux éditions euh du SER à
très bientôt sur sur Public Sénat